[Music]
me imm It's a failure
oen Security 2
iphone 4 Emu Shio Senbei Ochi ahkah Seg Let's follow every turn-
Then, the burning spring King f 1 line is
Yabe Fern Ah,
yes, it's an angle No. 3 for Japanese supplies  No
[Music] Hmm j [Music]
ren
dee
me
bejean
car
rar
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
amaran
mar
me
[Music]
Army  The lieutenant's work has come.
Stupid
4 minutes
4 days
Is there a guy who pays homage in a backpack
?
Spy is a Japanese memory
1945 book A
spy training school was secretly established in the army at the initiative of the Imperial Army officer Yuki.
Acquiring a wide range of foreign languages
ceutical physics Commu
ication technology Pract
cal training by professional musicians and addicts who break safes Vario
s skills were required, including how to persuade a woman by time, but i
is
hard to believe that
he Army Officer School  There were no graduates,
and it seemed that they were occupied by so-called locals who graduated from general universities such as the Imperial University.
There are
8 remaining students without monsters
[Music] I'm
going out to the city,
but how about Mr. Sakuma?
No,
I'll refrain from doing it
.  If
I were free, everything was different from the army officer school I graduated from.
The registration of the officer school is a relationship that vowed to devote myself to the country. You can give up your
life for them.
[Music]
However
, the students here are chewing on
Miyoshi and
beautiful Ota.
Mitsui
Hata
Fukumoto
Tazaki
All of their names were fake names.
I don't even know each other's real names while receiving
it. Why can I endure such a life?
[Music]
Goal
Two
Pairs 1 Pair
I'm also 1 pair
I'm
back so far
What are you doing
Come on, Kuma-san will join us?
Talker Car
Yes, let's play a little
Bed A
Call  Hmm
fold
Paul Dokkouru
[Music]
rise Lined up
me
Blaze Old
High
Full House
Poker Doo-I'm
still in the future
[Music]
There's no choice but
to
invite me again
Sakuma-san loses in poker  I don't know
what I mean, I was in 3rd place except for your card.
What's
the fun of winning by playing crazy? The
trees
weren't playing poker at all.
So what were you doing? It's called a joker game, but if it's a poker game,
it's a card game played at the table, but
it's just
a
sham.  I'll let you know by sign,
but
I don't know who's on which side. The
third place may be a fake, and I may change by reading the enemy's sign.
You can even put it on your side.
What's fun
and what's the point of deceiving each other?
Now,
it's like cold spring
international politics. What's the usual game in international politics
? Just Sakuma  If you don't agree
with me, I'm not saying how to win or lose. I'm saying that your way is cowardly.
What do you mean by what Japan is like now?
Washington.
Replace the table with the stage of international politics.
Information can't win the game if
it's out of the box.  That was the case in Japan at that time.
Players from other countries at the table one year
I
knew in advance how much information Japan was
going to have.  I didn't even realize the essence of the game
Forget
this is a spy training school
These guys
have to be scattered all over the world to make themselves invisible after leaving here
20 years 20 years
or longer alone in a strange land  Stop, melt into the land,
become an invisible existence, collect information on the
country, and engage in the work of giving it to your home country
. You can imagine what kind of life it is. Buy
[Music]
What is waiting for the future of disposal
Black  It ’s loneliness. What
if you ’re a spy? What to
do if you reveal your true identity. If you do n’t
kill the enemy, you ’ll decide on the spot
.  I don't know what it means If you know a
person in peacetime,
the police of that country will definitely start moving. It's
just a meaningless and stupid act such as a spy killing an enemy or self-determining without
thinking. It's a cowardly idea that fears death.
I still think that spies are cowardly beings.
Then listen.
If you die
, you'll be proud to meet the same person over there.
When you die, you'll die to brag because of that motive
.  What would you do if you could
n't meet?
Maru
Miyoshi Doumou Totology It's a
wonderful head of mine. It's well-prepared, but
it's the same as an emerging religion.
It's an opinion, for
example, if Japan loses the war,
you'll soon believe in the exact opposite as a preparatory activity.
Well,
if Japan loses the war,
loyalty to the honorary nation
or even a human priest.  Everything is fictitious. The
black loneliness that awaits you in the future.
Among them, the only thing that supports the disposition is the ability to make quick decisions
in a constantly changing situation
.  I don't work as a spy
for honor and patriotism, but
I have to be able to do this much. It's
just a terrifying pride. I have only one person
who can live like
that.
a Yes,
there is no doubt that the milk title material is a
little spy.
Watanabe
John Kobe I
came to Japan at the invitation of a major trading company three years ago. I am
undertaking inspection and confirmation work for precision machinery imported into
Japan. I rented a Japanese house in Kanda and ate rice with a tea bowl and
chopsticks.
A man who was arrested in another case said Gordon's name.
I'm expecting to give you the evidence that I did. If it's
evidence, what should I do? Now, even if I do
n't have any evidence, if I leave it alone,
it will disappear by myself.  There is a serious suspicion that the code was stolen secretly
. The
spy is over at the time of suspicion.
The voice is getting stronger. In other
words, this is a formal mission order to the d agency. Even
though it is a Wimirer mission, the
order is still an order.
Take the command of
I
'll accompany me as an interpreter.
It would be unnatural for the Japanese Army to step into a foreigner's house without an interpreter.
I don't think they can understand foreign languages.
I'll tell everyone that it's Maruhachi Marumaru
. Even if you step in, you're wondering what to do if you don't have evidence
.
[Music]
If you have it, it's the web.
Ah Curtain Fighters ev
Then 8 What do you remember? Princess Haru Keri France wayfarer Yes, I
'm ready. There
is no No. 2 in Japanese supplies. What did
you say to this guy?
[Music] I
searched the house and nothing came out.
I love Japanese culture because I'm angry at this place. I
also saw the geisha Ujiyama.
I'm just looking forward to the original family
.
[Music]
Jah
ana  released today
I ge collection
[music]
me
What is I myself re
La Vello hope we are ufi Before the break
, I'm a woman, but hey Jasuma 5 minutes
church hey
ios Good
[Music]
You guys shadow
once anyway
2  I won't forgive the second time.
What do you know about the second time? A few
days ago, the Constitutional Corps came and searched for it.
Of course
, I think
it's possible that nothing came out.  If that's the case, you
can't find a
codebook. Knowing that, [Music] Any trivial blunder is fine.
I did [Music]
Do you still look for it
? There is no place to go. There
is no intrusion. There is no episo.
There is no evidence to look for. I didn't have any
small firearms
.
]
That's why the sun awoke to purify
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
me
Ah ah ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
What you're looking for may be unexpectedly close